[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
[Musik]
guten abend hinein es kann niemand sagen
dass es keine warnungen gab heute wieder
vom chef der internationalen atomenergie
agentur der extrem besorgt ist dass der
krieg in der ukraine gerade rund um
europas größtes atomkraftwerk eskaliert
ausgerechnet dort es bestehe die sehr
reale gefahr eines nuklearen desasters
gestern musste ein block des
kernkraftwerks nach einem brand in der
anlage abgeschaltet werden russland und
die ukraine machen sich gegenseitig für
den angriff verantwortlich mehr jetzt
von dalian tag und nina niebergall
rauchschwaden über europas größtem
atomkraftwerk ins labor ich ja die
reaktoren seien unversehrt geblieben
heißt es heute von der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde
bis jetzt
die besitzer haben eine weitere extrem
riskante situation für alle in europa
geschaffen sie haben auf das
atomkraftwerk sabrina geschossen jeder
beschuss dieser einrichtung ist ein
offenes dreistes verbrechen ein
terrorakt
schon einmal stand die anlage unter
beschuss rückblick märz 2022
seither so sagt die ukraine haben sich
russische truppen auf dem gelände
verschanzt die russische armee verwendet
das kraftwerk erster linie als
munitionslager weiß eben weiß dass die
ukrainische armee die in den vergangenen
wochen die russischen munitionslager
systematisch angegriffen hat hemmungen
haben wird das akw selber anzugreifen
und durch eine explosion der munition
das akw zu riskieren hat die russische
armee die anlage also selbst beschossen
russland weist die vorwürfe zurück
erklärt stattdessen bewaffnete
ukrainische gruppen führten drei
artillerie schläge auf dem gelände des
kernkraftwerks sapori cia und in der
stadt in der huder aus
unabhängig überprüfen lassen sich die
angaben nicht die anlage ist veraltet
und wartungs bedürftig die
atomenergiebehörde spricht von einer
sehr realen gefahr einer nuklearen
katastrophe
die kämpfe konzentrieren sich
unterdessen zunehmend auf den süden der
ukraine wo eben auch so borussia liegt
die britische militär geheimdienstler
berichten dass russland truppen in
großem stil dorthin verlegt für die
menschen heißt das neue angst neues leid
anne brühl berichtet aus der stadt
nikolaev die nur noch wenige kilometer
von der front entfernt liegt
selbst die morgenmesse findet im keller
statt alles andere ist in der griechisch
katholischen gemeinde von nikolov zu
gefährlich es sind zeiten findet vater
terrasse in dem auch die kirche stellung
beziehen muss in seiner predigt wird er
deutlich
[Musik]
in diesen schweren zeiten des krieges
entscheiden wir uns für gott und den
dienst an unserem land der ukraine gott
gibt uns die kraft zu kämpfen
nach dem gottesdienst sind rauchschwaden
über den häusern auf der anderen seite
der bucht gut sichtbar wieder einmal
haben die russen die stadt mit raketen
angegriffen so ist das seit beginn des
kriegs
am ersten tag hat eine rakete die stadt
getroffen dann 20 40
alleine heute waren es wieder 20 wissen
sie ich gerate nicht in panik ich bin
stark und kontrolliert und ich bin
bereit zu den waffen zu greifen um für
meine stadt zu kämpfen
vor der kirche verteilen sie hilfspakete
der caritas die spendengelder dafür
kommen auch aus deutschland und vater
terrasse erklärt uns wie er als priester
das sieht mit dem krieg in seinem land
krieg ist immer negativ krieg heißt tod
verlust von leben krieg ist nicht liebe
krieg ist das böse aber wir haben diesen
krieg nicht angefangen mit super job
auf dem weg zu familien die auf die
lebensmittelpakete angewiesen sind hält
vater terrace plötzlich an mitten in der
stadt wieder ein einschlag vor einem
wohnkomplex das hier ist in der nacht
passiert
rudolf service caas heimatort ist nur 20
kilometer von nicolai auf entfernt dort
verläuft jetzt die frontlinie erzählt
sie uns eine ganze familie elf personen
auf der flucht
erst war es hier ruhig aber jetzt hören
wir die bombe hat muss auch hier wir
sind nervös können das nicht mehr
ertragen
wir haben einfach keinen ort an dem wir
gehen können
lubov ist witwer hat eine kleine rente
die lebensmittelpakete helfen da ein
bisschen
sie und ihre familie sind bei fremden
untergekommen kleider betten geschirr
alles geschenkt
darauf ist vater terrace stolz
solidarität und nächstenliebe auch in
zeiten des kriegs
jetzt in eine andere aufgewühlte gegen
dieser welt es gab in den letzten jahren
so viele kriegerische
auseinandersetzungen zwischen israel und
den radikalen islamisten im gazastreifen
das internationale beobachter dazu
übergegangen sind sie durch zu
nummerieren das verstellt den blick auf
das enorme leid das jede solche
eskalation den menschen bringt auf
beiden seiten die israelis müssen mit
ständigem luftalarm leben in die bunker
sprinten und hoffen dass ihre moderne
technologie den raketen terror aus gaza
abfängt für die zivilbevölkerung in gaza
gibt es kein alarmsystem und keine
schutzräume jede neue runde dieser
gewalt erinnert an die davor und endet
mit der gewissheit dass sie in
absehbarer zeit wieder neu beginnt
es ist zum verzweifeln auch aktuell
wieder wie andreas künast zeigt
als sich über gaza stadt der staub
verzieht ist vieles schlimmer und wenig
klarer israels militär veröffentlicht
diese bilder volltreffer auf einen
raketenwerfer des islamischen jihad
volltreffer auf ein waffenlager des
islamischen jihad volltreffer auf den
aufenthaltsort eines top offiziers des
islamischen jihad auf kaiser al jabari
und einige seiner mitkämpfer am tag
danach ist nicht klar wie viele
zivilisten es traf aber alles schlimmer
für islam und ihre schwester die einen
stock unter al dschabari lippen
[Musik]
wir waren zu hause als plötzlich das
fenster zerbrach als es plötzlich diesen
riesen angriff gab von oben sind steine
auf uns gefallen wir konnten nichts
sehen wir konnten nicht aufstehen es war
überall staunt
den getöteten kommandeur macht israel
für zahlreiche angriffe aus dem
gazastreifen verantwortlich der
islamische dschihad ist hier die
zweitstärkste kraft noch radikaler als
die hamas und noch enger mit israels
erzfeind iran verbunden
vergangenen nacht beginnt die vergeltung
mehr als 200 raketen feiert die
angegriffene organisation in richtung
israel ab vor allem im süden des landes
huston die menschen in die schutzräume
aber israels militär kann die meisten
raketen abfangen am abend trifft sich
das sicherheitskabinett in tel aviv
premier league gibt sich entschlossen
die operation falls nötig fortzusetzen
israel hat eine präzise anti terror
operation gegen eine unmittelbare
bedrohung durchgeführt wir kämpfen nicht
gegen das volk von gaza wir werden alles
tun um unser volk zu schützen
die israelischen angriffe treffen auch
heute einrichtungen des islamischen
jihad diese eskalation ist die
gefährlichste seit mehr als einem jahr
jetzt zurück nach deutschland mit diana
wegen der drohenden gasknappheit hat der
chef der bundesnetzagentur die
bevölkerung dazu aufgerufen deutlich
mehr energie zu sparen als bisher
privathaushalte müssten mindestens 20
prozent gas einsparen um einen mangel im
winter abzuwenden das sagte müller der
welt am sonntag außerdem müsste weniger
gas an die nachbarländer durchgeleitet
werden und deutschland bräuchte
zusätzliches gas aus anderen ländern
gut drei wochen vor dem ende des neuen
euro tickets ist die diskussion um eine
mögliche nachfolgeregelung in vollem
gange im zentrum steht dabei die
finanzierung bayerns verkehrsminister
bärenreiter sieht allein den bund in der
pflicht dagegen signalisierte die
vorsitzende der
verkehrsministerkonferenz schäfer dass
die länder durchaus bereit sein ein
nachfolger angebot mitzufinanzieren dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland sagte
sie das allerdings zunächst geklärt
werden müsse wie hoch der länderanteil
sei
der brand im berliner grunewald ist zwar
weitgehend gelöscht laut feuerwehr
besteht aber nach wie vor eine zitat
enorme gefahr auf dem sprengplatz wo
sich der boden extrem erhitzt hat der
sperrkreis von 1000 metern bleiben wohl
noch einige tage bestehen
die zugstrecke am rande der zone wurde
aber wieder freigegeben die autobahn a
bus bleibt mindestens dieses wochenende
gesperrt
in hiroshima ist an den atombombenabwurf
vor genau 77 jahren gedacht worden
bei der zeremonie im friedenspark warnte
un-generalsekretär gutes vor der
anhaltenden gefahr durch atomwaffen auch
mit blick auf den krieg in der ukraine
sie garantierten keine sicherheit nur
tod und zerstörung sagte görisch die usa
warfen am 6 august
1945 über hiroshima eine atombombe ab
schätzungsweise 140.000 menschen wurden
getötet
den appell zum sparen angesichts der
drohenden energiekrise haben wir ja
gerade wieder in der
nachrichtenübersicht gehört bei den
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden gibt es
aber noch eine andere sorge dass
extremisten die angst der menschen in
deutschland vor knapp im gas und hohen
preisen ausnutzen werden die szene
organisiere sich gerade neu berichtet
astrid randerath
sie gehen gegen die impfpflicht auf die
straße genauso wie gegen
waffenlieferungen
demonstranten am vergangenen sonntag in
berlin schlechte zeiten schlechte
stimmung wenn das gas teurer wird und
die korona maßnahmen schärfer ist dieser
protest voraussichtlich nur der anfang
also wir befürchten im herbst wenn die
szenarien so eintreffen wie wir sie
momentan einschätzen eine hochemotionale
exklusive und gewalttätige situation wo
es zu straßenprotesten kommen wird die
von extremisten unterwandert und geführt
werden dagegen ist das was wir in der
korona pandemie geliebt haben
wahrscheinlich eher ein kindergeburtstag
auch die innenministerin warnt heute
demokratie feinde warten nur darauf
krisen zu missbrauchen um untergangs
fantasie in angst und verunsicherung zu
verbreiten
laute buhrufe gegen robert habeck auf
seiner sommerreise verdi der
wirtschaftsminister schlechte
nachrichten verbreitet wird zur
zielscheibe hübner protestler genauso
wie rechter extremisten
die suchen gerade regelrecht nach neuen
feindbildern lange zeit war das große
motto war der rechtspopulistisch
rechtsextremen szene merkel muss das
heißt jetzt wird es um gesteuert es ist
nicht stolz aber wir leben halt dass der
vizekanzler habe ja auch zunehmend den
protest erfährt den lauten protest der
eben gar nicht mehr zu hören diese feind
besser sehen wir das bka beobachtet die
szene die polizei bereitet sich schon
jetzt vor denn es droht ein heißer
herbst zu werden
und jetzt die lottozahlen an diesem
samstag die lauten
18 16 27 30 46 superzahl 7 alle angaben
wie immer ohne gewähr
dann haben wir noch den blick auf die
sommerlichen wetter aussichten morgen
scheint häufig die sonne im norden eher
bewölkt bei 20 bis 30 grad in den
nächsten tagen sonnig teils heiß und
weiterhin zu trocken 20 bis 34 grad
ja morgen sonntag gibt es uns wieder und
der beginnt ja bereits in etwas mehr als
einer halben stunde hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit dem aktuellen sportstudio ein
schönes
[Musik]